make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay so we're getting back
into excalibur and we actually get to
see the return of him okay here's the
thing
technically he's not one of the most
powerful mutants marvel has
but i think he could be so like we get
to see this guy make his return now
what this does is this initially picks
up with morgan left those of you guys
who who have read this comic you guys
understand i'm not covering the first
three or four pages because i don't want
to spoil who the person is so
don't worry we will it'll all make sense
now remember morgan le faye has
basically taken over camelot that's
really kind of what happened with her
character the big issue that we run into
here and the big thing that we're trying
to struggle with here
is why she doesn't just leave camelot
right because what's really been going
on with her character is that you kind
of have these these gates of cocoa that
are popping up
all over the world not only that they're
actually popping up in other dimensions
too
uh where mutants who have resided there
or currently do reside there in some
form or fashion
can access now as far as we're aware
camelot is the only place we've seen
the only other dimension that exists out
there that we've seen people basically
access these gates and even then this
gets kind of finicky right because
technically camelot is inside otherworld
and another world exists outside of the
multiverse so the question becomes how
isakrika was able to reach beyond the
multiverse and into this other realm in
open gates right it's an almost
insurmountable amount of power right
because then the question becomes okay
can cocoa reach into like other
universes like create gates in
other universes that would seem to be
the case the difference here and this is
where things get a little interesting
the difference here is that we would
probably say
no because you can't just easily access
another universe in the same way that
you can when it comes to being able to
access the other world right being able
to access the realm of camelot and all
that kind of stuff
but the idea here is that when it comes
to like miriana stern the agent of
morgan le fay
in basically the main marvel universe
that their goal or at least the goal
that marianne has been tasked with is
essentially taking out the mutant threat
and like eliminating these gates right
because
really morgan lafaye just kind of sees
it as an encroachment on her power now
the reality in terms of why morgan
lafaye hasn't left camelot
entered into the main marvel universe
and solve this problem is because
presumably like as far as we're aware
king arthur is not there we don't know
where he is but we simply know he's not
there
and the indication seems to be that if
she left it would open the doors for
somebody to conquer camelot in her stead
and it's kind of a funny thing because
when she's talking to marianna
basically what marianna stern is saying
is like we know it has something to do
with the guy apocalypse but we're not
100
sure and it's kind of funny because the
response of morgan lafaye is well if you
think it's emanating from him then why
don't you defeat him right and that's
something that's much much easier said
than done
one does not simply walk up and defeat
apocalypse it doesn't just work that way
right the guys are so opaque but again
picking up with betsy braddock and these
guys one of the funny things to come
about this
is that jubilee's kid shogo basically is
able to tap into the power of
fairies um one of the things we also
didn't really do though people were
asking about this and we probably should
have done in the last video was offer
some measure of an explanation on shogun
shogu is not the biological child of
jubilee but i don't think she gave birth
to shogu or anything like that in x-men
vol 4 issue number one there was an
attempt there was really the creation of
a character called arkan who was kind of
like the sister of john sublime the
bacterial entity sublime and it was
really kind of building off what it was
that grant morrison had done during his
run on new x-men but essentially archaea
was making his return you know back to
earth and there was like a meteor shower
in this small village and basically
everybody in the area was killed but
jubilee found this baby that was
essentially you know its parents were
gone and she ultimately adopted it and
that's basically where shogo comes from
right like just a quick and dirty
explanation and it's basically been
around ever since right now the reality
is it was one of the cool introductions
for jubilee because it kept her
character interesting as opposed to her
having been like this vampire at one
point but not really kind of something
along those lines it's a little strange
your character had actually kind of been
free floating in marvel
ever since generation x came to an end
that was really like where a character
peaked in popularity i think it was but
the overall gist of this is that when
the baby passed through the dimensional
barrier from the main marvel universe
into uh otherworld
somehow it was able to tap into the
power of fairies and we're not really
given like a true explanation on how
it's one of these things where like
they're kind of musing on it and betsy
braddock's just kind of like well i mean
it's a mortal baby in this realm so it's
exceedingly powerful
the indication seems to be that because
it's a baby and because it has such such
an imagination
ultimately it can kind of tap into those
magical abilities that are there whereas
as adults you know as you become
educated your your imagination becomes
less of a
significant thing you know with regards
to how your mind works but we're not
really given a hard and fast explanation
but the long and short is that
ultimately shogo just kind of takes on
the form that it wants to now
the fact remains here that of course one
of the big things you kind of get and
this is one of the cool things this is
why gambit's cool depending on how he's
written right and in more
in recent years he wasn't wasn't nearly
as interesting to you as he was like
right after the events of x-men the
animated series right like and actually
in the animated series i think is when
he probably
reached his highest level of popularity
but in the years it kind of came after
for about two years after the show went
off the air he was still pretty cool and
then he just kind of became a background
character
but his love of rogue is what makes him
interesting right because with his
powers just being the ability to
basically kinetically charge
objects it's okay i mean it's like okay
cool you know whatever it's a fraction
of what it used to be right you read the
new sun story it's just like dude this
guy could have just like blown up
planets
but focusing on the human side of him
that's what makes him interesting and
one of the things that he does is he
basically lashes
out at jubilee and at uh betsy braddock
right because he's like none of you all
here you can pitch me whatever story you
want to but rogue is literally sitting
in a box on the other side of this
dimension you know and she's just kind
of there by herself and we have no idea
what's going on with her not only that
she's being watched over by apocalypse
the last character in the world i would
ever trust and remember gamut's not just
saying this to say it he's saying it
because he was a horseman of apocalypse
once
he has an intimate understanding both
through that experience as well as
having fought apocalypse multiple times
over the years that apocalypse is not
necessarily the most trustworthy
character out there and so putting the
life of rogue in the hands of a
character who's dubious at best you know
and who is incredibly overpowered and
could potentially even take rogue and
turn her into a horseman because it
suits what it is that he wants to do is
the last thing gambit wants to do and
it's his stance here is like you guys
never would have left somebody over
there like that right like you jubilee
actually
went to the other dimension and got your
child and brought him back because you
didn't want him to be there with
apocalypse you betsy braddock never
would have left
somebody that you cared about in the
hands of apocalypse but you're telling
me with a straight face that i need to
do it because it's the right thing to do
get out of here and it's it's so cool
because it's like you guys are so full
of crap you guys are pitching me this
because you want to complete a mission
you don't care about rogue you care
about your mission like what you care
about is getting brian braddock back and
you'll say whatever you need to in order
to make it happen it's amazing like it's
this amazing back and forth because what
it does is it shows how much gambit
cares about rogue in his mind there's
rogue and then
everything else and that's true based on
the interactions the two have had over
the years and even
the story that we got when they were
married for a short amount of time like
gambit
you know like any man who's in love with
the woman that he's with would let the
world burn before he let anything happen
to her and it's
a cool thing to see that in the
character of gambit because it makes him
more tangible and more relatable and i
think it's probably some of the best
handling of his character in quite some
time actually so
i love seeing his character depicted in
this faction the issue with this is of
course once they basically end up
traveling to the castle of morgan lafaye
in an effort to basically try to break
in and get brian braddock when they get
there then like they're met by all these
magically enhanced nights and the
results of this is that what you also
end up getting
is the inability for betsy braddock to
dominate their minds all she can do is
read her read their surface thoughts now
this is a byproduct of of morgan le faye
basically using her magics to kind of
protect her various knights that are
there and that's one of the important
things to understand is that while
morgan lafaye doesn't really play a hand
in dealing with like the x-men right you
don't really see her fight the x-men
she's not oblivious to them right it's
not like she's unaware of what the x-men
can do or what they're capable of and
even people with just telepathy right
because he actually not the only ones
who have it being able to
understand that power and understand
what someone like betsy brady can do and
then fortify her forces against that
really show just how capable morgan left
is and so what you end up getting here
is brian braddock who again
was previously transformed into the
black knight who arrives on the scene
now remember
the longer he stays under the spell of
morgan le faye the longer he stays under
her control
the further and further he gets away
from himself and so what you get are
these small little moments here and
there
like he basically goes to attack betsy
braddock the two of them fight and you
get these small little moments right
where she's mentioning names like megan
the wife of brian braddock where she's
saying things like your brother jamie
has come back and so on and so forth and
some of these things kind of resonate
with him to a degree but before anything
can happen suddenly of course you
basically have shogun who shows up uses
dragonflame to kind of spray everything
down
and brian seems to kind of have this
recollection of who he is but then he's
whisked away by morgan le faye and so
what it does is it kind of gives us this
little bit of a glimpse you know with
the possibility that brian can make his
return
maybe he'll go back to being captain
britain maybe it'll be betsy braddock
right i mean you know brian has been
captain britain for
decades so maybe it's time for somebody
else to take over the mantle but he is
also a mainstay
in in like the british side of marvel
comics right i mean it's like it's like
if steve rogers was no longer captain
america anymore right i mean you could
lose the mantle but then ultimately if
you've been reading marvel comics long
enough you know that he would come
back right so that's exactly how it is
with brian braddock so that's why it's
kind of cool to see this because for me
it's not
it's not really an issue of oh my god
brian braddock's never going to be
captain britain again right he foolish
of me to believe that but what what
is interesting to me is how's it going
to come back and go back to being
captain britain again that's what i want
to see
that's what intrigues me and so as a
result of this what you end up having is
really apocalypse kind of getting
frustrated with his ability to
understand how these magics work with
regards to like other world and the
druid magics and the magics of planet
cabba those individuals who
were once you know led by apocalypse who
ultimately abandoned his inability to
really tap into magic now this is
important because what this shows is
it's really kind of an unofficial
weakness of apocalypse not a physical
weakness not in so far as like if faced
by somebody who can use magic he will
ultimately be defeated uh what it means
is that like there are elements and
things out there
that apocalypse still doesn't really
understand and that's kind of important
because of course he's been around for
five thousand years but it's one of
these things where marvel's basically
saying yes he's old but he has not seen
and done it
all he's seen and done a lot and so it's
kind of a cool little thing because what
he says is like okay i can't really tap
into these things i can't really like
control these these stones the way that
i need to
i need to find someone who can and so
what he ends up doing here is actually
leaving cornwall
and then traveling to like central park
it looks like and people just kind of
like dude is that such and such and it's
just kind of like you don't stare man
like don't stare and it's kind of crazy
he just like boldly walks through the
park
and makes his way finally to like this
apartment complex and when he walks in
there he rips the door
off this apartment you know this kid's
like what the heck is going on and
apocalypse just like be quiet kid like
you need to come with me now the
question is
who is this kid this kid is julio
richter
also known as simply just richter and he
is one of the most
powerful mutants in marvel comics i
think now he's not powerful insofar as
he has like extreme reality manipulation
powers or anything like that he does
have clairvoyance uh that is to say the
ability to like see into the future
understand people's emotions different
things like that but i think probably
the the really the main focal point of
his power
is the ability to control the earth he
was one of those characters that
originally lost his powers during the
events of house of m and then during
children's crusade got his powers back
but like that's the thing like
sometime really recently like you know
during the events of house and powers of
x he seemed to have lost control of them
and so he was always kind of afraid of
going to kokoa because he was afraid he
would shake the island apart the reality
and this is one of the important things
apocalypse is just like one you can't be
afraid you have to learn to harness your
power right your power is part of you
you have to learn to harness and control
it but two apocalypse makes a very
important thing he's like you can
basically alter
and and like change the world miles
below the surface right now
what this does and this is one of the
funny things about him by my definition
of omega level it makes him an omega
level threat or at least an omega level
mutant and the reason why is because his
power is literally like earth-based
meaning he's a danger to the earth
itself now
technically speaking omega level is like
there's no definitive upper limit to
that power
and because of the fact that he
manipulates planets i would say that
like if given enough time if he's able
to like control it enough he could move
like other planets and things like that
which would be absolutely
beast to be able to see but richter's
like one of these unsung heroes of
marvel like one of these unsung heroes
of the x-men but that's the thing like
like literally this guy could just like
crack the earth in two if he wanted to
and that's what he's afraid of right
like being unable to control his powers
that like they would eventually go awry
and who basically crack the earth in
half
he would destroy the entire world it's
what he's afraid of and he actually
could like he legitimately could if he
lost control over his powers were pushed
to the extreme all you would need is the
same kind of scenario to unfold
after emma frost woke up from her coma
when she was attacked or at least when
all the hellions died and then she took
over the body of iceman and then
realized that like bobby drake is an
omega level mutant if his powers are
pushed high enough that's the exact same
thing you need with richter but that's
why he's basically been brought in
by apocalypse is like i need you to be
able to one like use your clairvoyance
powers and then two to also use your
powers to control the earth to help me
basically understand everything going on
with these stones and so on and so forth
but what we also end up finding out here
is that mi13 is on the hunt for the new
captain or
for captain britain because it's a
necessary character for england itself
and the person who shows up here is none
other than pete wisdom now pete wisdom
is
cool he's not really cool in terms of
powers he's got these like you know
solar knives basically like these these
flaming knives he absorbs like ambient
solar energy and then creates like
knives out of him and stuff like that
but what it basically
means is like marvel's pulling out all
the stops so like a lot of the british
characters things are about to pop off
it's basically what this means
the excalibur stories are gearing up for
some pretty big things but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
if you guys are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
we've got some new patrons in our top
tiers over on patreon.com
comics explain i want to give a shout
out to jason c austin
s austin h phillip and austin b as well
as
steven z eagle f joey m and jeff
r as well as genosis 916. as always we
just usually keep the last name to an
initial
it helps you guys to maintain your
anonymity some of you guys have
expressed concern about having like your
first and last name thrown out there for
the world to see
i do not blame you for you guys who have
joined up as part of our patreon tiers
that are eligible
for rob core honor guard rings those
whose rings have been sent out you
should already have them
if you're a new person who just joined
up and you've been part of this tier
four month
your ring will be mailed out to you so i
want to say thank you guys
for being patrons
[Music]
[Music]
you